of course the holidays are upon us I'm
sure we're all familiar with the
traditional nativity scene that people
put up around the holidays right you
know manger wise men baby Jesus blah
blah blah at least Germany it is 2019
and we thought the nativity could use a
little updating for younger people don't
you agree yeah yeah thank you thank you
thank you applause was a little late but
I'm gonna take it it's the premise of
the sketch we're gonna update the
nativity that's right so we're
introducing ladies and gentlemen get
excited some new nativity characters for
example instead of the Virgin Mary we
have vemma a popular beauty blogger you
won't be a virgin no more after I show
you this bold smoky eye very nice yes
and then check out over here the little
drummer boy and camel had been replaced
by spider-man with his therapy dog and
of course baby Jesus is now baby Yoda
yeah
hey man the hell is this thing what is
this
I dig it's supposed to be baby Yoda this
looks this looks absolutely terrible
where's our prop Supervisor John Rao can
you come out here please
hey Conan okay John what's up with this
second-rate baby Yoda it's awful
Disney didn't release any baby Otis in
time for Christmas so we had to make one
oh well I'm sorry but this is this is
right this is awful this is not good
enough I want you to go out and find a
real authentic baby Yoda do whatever it
takes all right yeah how do you have any
baby
in Yoda's no okay thanks bye yeah hi do
you have any baby Otis why oh da yeah I
know they're popular b8b why there's no
need to use that kind of language all
right
all right bye MA
[Music]
all right hello
wait oh okay
so you guys see the irishman yeah too
long
you here for your talk but what are you
going to give me a lot
do whatever it takes this is for you
counting
[Music]
I got baby Yoda for you well you did get
baby Yoda this is incredible yeah yeah
hey how did you do it this is amazing
how did you do it
traded my liver for it those jokes on
them it doesn't work you'll be dead soon
hey thanks a lot John oh hey baby
[Applause]
you